did you know it's actually super easy to
become a voice actor all you need is one
of these one of these I find it highly
important to let you guys know that if
you are someone who wants to become a
voice actor in the future you're going
to have a much more difficult time if
you use a USB microphone now of course
none of this applies to little YouTube
fan projects or anything necessarily but
if you want to become an actual voice
actor you shouldn't be buying a USB mic
invoice acting sound is your only tool
it is all that matters and to that end
USB mic no matter how expensive just
don't meet the minimum standard USB mics
convert from analog to digital
themselves rather poorly whereas an
actual audio interface with attached XLR
mic performs that conversion way better
it doesn't matter what studio what era
if you've ever seen any footage of an
actual voice actor acting themselves
they're using XLR you can get both an
XLR mic and audio interface for like
$150 nowadays